[Musique]
le Conseil départemental et la Région
Réunion célébré ce dimanche 10 juillet
la fête de l'ï oufitre qui marque la fin
du mois sacré de Ramadan à la villa du
département les deux collectivités ont
souhaité partager ce moment chaleureux
qui rassemble des personnes toutes
confession confondu une fête
représentative du vivre ensemble
réunionnéis années on se pose la
question et on l'a posé avec le
président de Région est-ce qu'il faut
garder ici dans les collectivité
territorial des fêtes qu'on appelle des
fêtes communautaires culturelles et
cultuell ou bien au contraire est-ce
qu'il faut rentrer et donner le visage
d'une laïcité neutre et ben nous avons
choisi plutôt de garder le modèle
réunionné qui transmet le vivre ensemble
moi je suis indienne de confession
musulmane mais depuis tant petit comme
il ça va à l'église avec mon bon
camarade comme il ça va à la messe comme
il ça va l'enterrement des camarades
Tamou ben apprendre à connaître comment
l'autre il vive c'est quoi sa foi ou
même sa non foi moi j'ai des amis qui
sont at c'est ce vivre ensemble là qu'il
ne faut pas perdre à la Réunion parce
que il représente l'idéal
français républicain que nous avons bien
que étant chinoise d'origine mais ayant
vécu avec que dans toute ma famille avec
une un mélange de
religion bouddhisme chrétien et je
trouve tout à fait normal qu'à la rayon
on puisse pouvoir célébrer les fêtes de
d'autres communautés qui composent
également notre terroir notre terrain
régionnis pour le groupe de dialogue
interreligieux de la Réunion la
diversité du peuple réunionné et sa
capacité à vivre ensemble sont sans
aucun doute les plus grandes richesses
de l'île effectivement nous avons ici un
islam paisible
un islam qui a trouvé ici un terrain
pour s'épanouir totalement la
célébration de Laï comme la célébration
des autes fêtes sont des moments de
partage et c'est ça qui est qui fait
l'originalité de la Réunion c'est la
part faite à l'ensemble des de la
diversité à la fois culturelle et
spirituelle chacun a sa place
et chacun apporte quelque chose dans
dans se vivre ensemble réunionn divers
animation on été mise en place tel que
la calligraphie le aîné mais aussi des
ateliers liques pour les enfants alors
c'est une association qui propose des
ateliers pendant les
vacances scolaires ou comme aujourd'hui
pendant des fêtes de ce type aux enfants
de faire des petites créations et un peu
ludique et puis aussi pour décharger un
peu les parents aujourd'hui on propose
deux types de de magnettes donc ce sont
des petits petits avions pour les
garçons et des papillons pour les filles
par rapport à l'histoire du aîné donc
effectivement il a été lancé sur les
pays maghrébains notamment en Afrique et
à la base c'était un outil de séduction
et de maquillage c'était pour se faire
belle parce qu'à l'époque il
n'existaient pas les produits de beauté
tels que les crayons ni les rouges à
lèvres donc on se faisait belle en se
faisant des ornements sur la peau des
bijoux et ensuite lorsque les musulmans
ont quitté l'Afrique pour partir vers
les Indes ils ont ramené cet art avec
eux et aujourd'hui c'est devenu un air
indomusulman donc autant pour la
communauté Tamou et autant pour la
communauté musulmane mais à la base
c'était pour les futurs mariés ça
éloignaé le mauvais œil en fait ça
apporté bonheur et fécondité aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que par rapport au motif il
est devenu moderne on le fait sur la
cuisse sur la cheville sur le poignet on
le fait un petit peu partout un mois de
jeûne qui a permis à la communauté
musulmane de se recueillir la fête de
l'aï à la villa du département reflète
bien l'esprit de partage si important
pour les musulmans durant ce mois
[Musique]
sacré